the reason actually that much to do if
once you want to end up with is y equals
MX plus B now what I want you to do is
because I asked you if you were in a
pair to start with three different
points one some of you started paid and
some of you started with Q now if you
put in y equals MX plus B form
regardless of which point you started
with you should find that you end with
this guy okay now just think about this
for a second right that shouldn't be
surprising you're both finding the
equation of the same line right and you
know that they both should be on there
but this should be a little trickier
wait why does it happen if unlike me you
chose a left-hand point or you got
pulled to to the left endpoint okay you
would have had a Q squared here a Q
squared over here and then when you
expand it out the right-hand side you
would have had the same a q squared
there or you might have had it if you
did your order by you'd have it here and
your AP q would be over here right so
the same terms would cancel out on this
side and you'd be left with the same
thing at the bottom okay so there's my M
that half P plus Q I already identified
the gradient and there would be my
corresponding y-intercept babe okay now
it's just worth 30 okay the fact that
you could put in P or Q P or Q and you
will get the same thing at the other end
this has a little on a name this is
called symmetric in whichever variables
you put in you will get the same thing
at the other end okay because a chord PQ
is the same as the chord QP it's the
same line okay so we call this equation
symmetric in pinch you and there will be
a variety of other ones that we get
where regardless of which one you put in
it doesn't matter you'll get the same
thing because it's the same way okay
right so let me mention again this is
the first I'll put a box around it this
is the first of a series of equations
that you will meet under parametric's of
the problem you do not need to memorize
them do not need to memorize it if at
memorizing them
and reproducing them in an exam is a
problem because often you'll be asked to
prove this guy okay you won't be able to
just say quote that in a laugh and there
there's what I have as an equation right
you'll be given points and you'll have
to prove that this is the case or
alternatively if the question is being
nice or it's trying to assist something
else they will say the equation of a
cord is and do not prove this they'll
actually tell you not to prove it yet
you see does it we do it because
sometimes the focus is not on this
process but on can you use this for
something else okay
so therefore don't memorize it but I
would like you to look at it and say
okay I generally get what that looks
like and with I see it again I'll
recognize it and I'll think yeah this is
what I was supposed to get I can march
on them something interesting before we
for show you the animation okay
this chord is a chord P cube regardless
of where P and Q could be on the table
but there's a particular family of
chords that is more interesting namely I
guess on this one it will be somewhere
around here
the set Accords the pass through the
focus okay those chords because they
passed through the focus are called
focal points so if I have a chord like
say
if I've got a cord the goes through
anywhere but it passes through s which
is on this one zero a and obviously if I
had some kind of shift or is upside down
it would be elsewhere and I have
corresponding coordinates we call this
guy in critical point now vocal cords
are quite an interesting and it's really
easy to see one if this is the equation
of a court right and crosses through the
focus that means zero a should satisfy
this equation right it should satisfy
that guy so I'm gonna say if I should be
able to put in these coordinates and out
will come something true right because
it should be able to satisfy this
equation so zero is my x coordinate and
ay be my y coordinate let's pop this in
to see what happens there is my y
coordinate because X is zero all of this
becomes zero and there's that Y
disappear over on the right hand side
there you look at that you know I caught
on this again if I just rearranged us
just a little bit right assuming that a
is nonzero because I'm gonna divide
through by it in a second okay and pops
this now remember we established last
lesson and I just remind you again this
morning
what are P and Q gradients P and Q are
the gradients of these two points right
these two points here and here or there
and there or wherever you live right so
what this is telling you right because
because these are gradients this is this
situation right well I should say this
right that's what really means and of
course you know what it means when
gradients multiply together to give
negative one it means that these two
guys here and it
engines OD this will not work well you
use your imagination okay
they gonna be perpendicular right now
rather than showing you some like no
very accurate diagram let me actually
show you what its gonna look like gt-r I
spin this around
wow I'm impressed
thank you that's penny you might have to
tell on screen consumer Brian I didn't
thanks that's all right so he's our
parabola okay now you can by the way you
can completely replicate what I've done
here I believe I can save you the link
but it's more fun to actually just do it
myself
oh I just I did just x squared equals 4
ey when you do that because it
recognizes x and y has the you know your
coordinate axes it says it starts to
grab but then it says what egg like do
you want a to be something so you click
on the button you get a slider then
you've done this before okay once you've
done that you get this graph okay you
can put in the corners of the focus
because it's just gonna be your a and
you will pop it in there we go okay and
you can see if I want to I can change
this parabola to be we can make it you
know and the focus drops in closer to
the public as the focal length is
smaller or I could make it fatter and
the football length is larger so that's
why the focus moves away from the vertex
you see that by focal length er has
increased if I had the directrix
language happens to be not very
interesting but it would drop down long
okay so
okay now what you can then do is say
well I want I'm interested in a pair of
points to a pee-pee sweat to a qaq squid
and where you start to talk that it'll
say well what's cute and what's B so you
can add some slices of it now you have a
look right where am i paying Q at the
moment he's paid right now it's 0.6 0.6
what does this tell you about P it's the
it's the orange point can you see it
then orange orange okay what does your
punching to me it's the gradient that
looks bad right doesn't it you can see
it's a pretty shallow kind of line and
if of course I increase it something
like this you can see it moves off to
somewhere where there's a corresponding
gradient I guess the gradient back will
be two point three okay and you I've got
everything on the other side q is our
end point over the left hand side why is
it on the left hand side because I want
a gradient is negative and the only
place on this problem where the gradient
is negative is over there on the
negative x dollars okay so you can
recognize down here underneath my
coordinates there's our equation we've
just derived so let's show you so
there's my focal court sorry there's my
court it's just any old court and I can
move P and Q any which way I like and
you will see the cord goes and follows
it now if I want a focal cord right then
this quality must be true
this quality must be true so there's a
variety of ways you can do that one here
but what I could do is I could lock in
one of the parameters for example I
could pop in Q and say if they multiply
to be minus one then one has to be the
negative reciprocal of the other do you
agree with that that's another way to
see the gradients so let's do that let's
replace this guy
this okay so what can you see now right
that is expected there is my um my grade
point in the middle there which we
define as the focus I can read the focus
somewhere else in my life and it will
still do it stink good and as I move
around as I change where the points are
you're always going to get something
passing through the focus okay now just
to show you again what I tried to do but
but failed because what wife
illustration was not very accurate okay
if those gradients should multiply
together to give this then spoilers
we'll do this off to the AP twos if I
put in those two tangents yeah and yeah
right can you see wherever I guard let's
move around now you can see the tangents
are always going to be perpendicular if
the court passes through the focus
yeah well it's the theorem I get out of
this right but if it goes through the
focus it has to do this they have to be
at right angles to each other